welcome to the science Asylum I am Miss
lucid so in the comments of my vectors
video puzzle master asks can you do a
video on vectors and their application
in physics with electromagnetism that
will be mind-blowing please
well puzzle master prepare to have your
mind blown most vectors in
electromagnetism or what you call vector
fields oh you mean like force fields and
sci-fi shows not again the entertainment
industry has misused the word field for
so long that it's become standard to use
it that way it's never a good idea to
learn your science from sci-fi remember
sci-fi is short for science fiction I
mean don't get me wrong I like sci-fi as
much as the next gig it makes for good
entertainment just not good education
I'm getting off-topic
if you've tried to look this stuff up
online or in a book somewhere you've
probably seen something like this or
maybe in 3d like this they call this the
electric field of a dipole physics
teachers have a fetish with dipoles for
some reason anyway the lines in this
diagram are called field lines and books
will have them for electric fields
magnetic fields and sometimes even
gravitational fields this isn't really
what a field is with pictures like this
it isn't even clear why they're called
fields you might be thinking at this
point then why do we even draw them this
way because humans are lazy creatures
what a field really looks like is kind
of a pain to draw by hand which 100
years ago was the only way to draw
things see a century ago a bunch of
scientists got together one day and
decided to accept a little loss of
information and draw fields using lines
the key point here being that these
diagrams don't tell you everything the
fields can so the use is kind of limited
if you don't already understand fields
we can do better in the vectors video we
said position was a way of assigning
numbers to places all the places this
has the benefit of turning geometry into
algebra and arithmetic field is the same
thing in fact you could call this a
position field although no one ever does
it even looks like a field say a
football field or a minefield this is a
field of values position is not the only
number we can assign to these places if
it's just numbers we're assigning then
we call it a scalar field like the
voltage in this diagram for a positive
point charge if those numbers also have
direction then we call it a vector fee
like the electric field in this diagram
for the same positive point charge which
is actually the direction of the largest
change in the voltage numbers you can
even make diagrams like this for
multiple charges let's say you've got
this one positive charge over here then
an equal but negative charge over here
this is the electric field for the one
on the left this is the electric field
for the one on the right and here they
are overlapping now let's say we were to
place another really tiny charge about
here first it's not going to care what
the entire field looks like it only
cares about the field where it happens
to be second it's not going to respond
to both these fields separately only the
combination of the two this is called
superposition and it can be done with
all of the arrows in the full diagram if
you play a game of connect the dots you
can get that stupid line diagram we were
talking about before this same process
can be done for the electric field for
two positive charges or five random
charges or the magnetic field from two
circular coils or even the gravitational
field from the earth and the moon the
point here is that it's best to think of
vectors like velocity acceleration and
force as though they are attached to
objects and think of vector fields as
though they are attached to space got
another mind-blowing question asked in
the comments and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
you